let's talk about the ubi it recently
came out I think it's Pelosi and and
some of you know kind of her peers but
doesn't matter who it is is now
proposing the idea of folks getting a
digital wallet and receiving these ubi
payments potentially through a digital
dollar what do you kind of take from
from this whole idea of everyone hates
Libre and Bitcoin you know 12 months ago
to now we're talking about potentially
paying ubi via a digital dollar into a
digital wallet to me it sounds like
they're speeding up the adoption of
Bitcoin I mean think about it you're
gonna have immediate clearance of
transactions in the Bitcoin so before if
they were doing ubi check step two
they're Bank of America account and then
they had to clear it and whatever I mean
it's just I think it's gonna be a faster
clearance of transactions time into a
sound monetary baseline currency and
there's definitely no difference in it
being pegged which is the issue so
unless and even if they did say it was
pegged I don't think anyone would
believe it so I know I wouldn't I would
immediately swap it into Bitcoin if I
received it and I think anybody who
understands what's happening is gonna do
the exact same thing so if anything
they've just accelerated the speed at
which Bitcoin adoptions gonna happen by
doing it so sure have at it
yeah then one of the reasons why last
year on television I started talking
more and more about the digital doll or
was I thought that there was kind of a
win-win situation which was the u.s. if
other countries were to digitize their
currency in the US did not we didn't
have a digital dollar there is a big
risk to the dollar becoming less
accessible to people around the world
right if I can all of a sudden with an
internet connection login and I can buy
the digital wand or a digital ruble or
something like that but I can't get a
digital dollar there's an accessibility
challenge and therefore I'm going to
store my wealth in another currency if
for
I don't live in Bitcoin but then the
second piece is well if they're gonna
digitize the dollar then they're gonna
have to get everyone digital wallets and
just like you said I think that once you
start handing people digital wallets
humans aren't stupid right and they're
gonna realize very quickly wait a second
there's one that's a deflationary type
currency that has the ability to be
provably scarce versus I've got this
inflationary thing which if you look at
the Fed's balance sheet from last week
literally it looks like it went
parabolic right and that they added
three hundred fifty six billion dollars
which is the highest increase in a week
ever right and so I think just when you
start thinking about where does an
entire generation of people put their
kind of wealth and where do they trust
well they trust the thing that they can
prove and so if you're gonna hand people
digital wallets you know like you said I
think you're just accelerating bitcoins
kind of rise in popularity I mean if
you've got a billion dollars and you got
to send it to into another currency and
it takes hours or a day to get a
clearance of transaction on that you've
got to take out some type of I would
think a smart person would look at that
and say all right what's my what's my
volatility risk for this specific
currency into the other one and they've
got to take out a derivatives contract
in order to protect that with with
digital tokens you get your clearance at
transactions near immediate right so
you're taking that frictional cost of
protecting that volatility risk through
the time that it takes to clear
completely out of the equation so you
know the countries that are gonna be the
last movers on that I don't know that I
would step out and say that it's gonna
be the demise of that currency by any
shape of the imagination but it's
definitely gonna push people
corporations and nations to adopt a
different form of of currency I mean
it's just it's just it's just silly man
when you look at when you look at how
obvious some of this is you just gotta
shake your head and just say my god how
are people not getting this